for somebody who's looking at the
young universe at the early universe
and are talking about God and our
agnostic
who do you think is God hmm
so I thought you had just like one of
the best podcasts with Sam Harris this
past summer and
um one of the things I liked about that
conversation is he talked a lot about
happiness and meditation
and he says something that's really
resonated with me and I've been working
around and trying to work on it my own
way but he said like you can never
you can never be happy
you could only become happy
and I've tried to take a little bit
further than that because I think it's
interesting like meditation is like
you're not like oh I'm happy and now
like oh my kid came in and I'm not happy
they're like no like you can be
satisfied Kurt Vonnegut said like son
you ever catch us sometimes unless
you're like walking around you're like
life is freaking amazing like I'm happy
and Kurt Vonnegut said you should say to
yourself every time that happens like a
little Mantra like if this isn't
goodness if this isn't happiness nothing
is just remind yourself how awesome it
is every breath everything that you do
when you make an impact even some of the
bad stuff that happens good it's good so
Sam said that and it made me think
because I was like well
what does it really mean to to be happy
because like I can think of
um I can think of about you know two or
three ways that right now I could double
my happiness now like win the lottery or
whatever like I could double my habit
there's only a few ways though right
like
you know I had uh this this kind of
thought like how many boats can you
water ski behind like you had twice as
many followers now you got two million
followers five whatever it doesn't do
anything it's called the hedonic
treadmill like once you get to a certain
level it takes a lot more you know
change and followers money impact women
whatever you want to make you have one
more quanta of Happiness right on the
other hand
this is a concept from entropy I could
make your life miserable in an infinite
number of ways in other words there's
more stay space to make your life
unhappy than happy
and so I thought about that in the
context of what Sam said about happiness
um so it's sort of like yeah it's an
expression of entropy and that what you
should be doing in life is doing that
which will cause you Devastation if it
goes away
because those are the things that like
are where you're reducing
entropy like a kid like anyone who's a
parent
knows instantly what I'm talking about
like how to make your life a billion
times worse but there's no way to make
your life a billion times better
and so thinking about that now turning
into the question of God's existence
I feel like there's no way that you can
believe in God to quote misquote Sam but
there's ways that you can become a
believer in other words you could
increase the Bayesian confidence level
that there is some and let's not call it
God because it's a freighted term let's
just call it some Infinite Source of
goodness or our beautiful power in the
universe right simple things can do that
you can increase your credulity in the
goodness of life and we have this bias
as humans towards negativity negativity
bias well-known fact
so what I want to do is is let's call
God good right that's where it comes
from God good same words in German
and when we think about what is good
let's do those things
that would devastate us
and a lot of that could be relationships
and there's a powerful concept from
um from Network Theory which is that you
know the number of Connections in a
network you know I'm just saying it for
everyone it grows as the square of the
elements of the Matrix and the number
right so you think of a matrix with n
people you know person one two three
four and then there's four other people
there's 16 different pairs but two half
of them overlap the diagonal is where
you know each other you know yourself so
there's but that still grows as N
squared
so those connections increase and
decrease right you ever have two friends
that are fighting and like you're kind
of upset even though you're not fighting
with either one of them so like a
network grows like that so you want to
increase your network as much as
possible but only the kind of high
quality interstices between them and I
think in doing so you're in you you make
yourself fragile not anti-fragile and I
think that is where purpose and maybe
approaching some notion of God can come
from so that is a source of meaning
maximizing the goodness in life and the
way you know is good is if it's taken
away it would devastate you
that's one way
think about it your brand your business
your spouse your kids
I mean parents can't count though I've
known parents that have a lot Jim Simons
here's a perfect example he's one of my
oldest friends and mentors
he is one of the richest people on earth
Gulfstream mega yacht this is all
documented books about
um he lost two sons as adults
and I hear people say oh I'm so jealous
of Jim Simons
would you take everything
I don't know where he has that strength
and his wife Marilyn and his first wife
Barbara
I'm not I'm not like that some people
are there are angels that walk among us
and
you know there's this famous prayer it's
like you know uh God you know there's an
old saying like one of the hardest tests
there are in life is to be given a lot
of money and you see it like happens
with like lawyer like people that win
the lottery or whatever or NFL football
players after their career is over they
got they're broke right and I always
like God please test me with money you
know that'd be great but but in reality
you should never say I'm gonna I want
what x person has unless you're willing
to take everything and you'll find you
won't want to take everything